dude i went to the
i went with david spade over to the
oscars uh after parties
and that was interesting
you know and [ __ ] oscars man you know
yeah you know i don't like all of that
[ __ ]
you know i don't like hollywood
or much of it
and um
but
getting to go with him and stuff like
that was real interesting
and i was overhead at his house we
watched the oscars at uh at david's home
and
they had the cr you know the chris rock
got hit
and i was thinking about that
and
i think there was
so many people have talked about it
right that and that's
that is what it is
but
i think there was like a um
there was like a moment where
part of the anger
was that here you have somebody who's
just saying something right chris rock
now i get he's jabbing at the guy's wife
i get that
um
but also he's a comedian
he should be able to do that or he
should be able to take his risks
and i felt like it was a calculated risk
it felt super safe
um
but there was something about how
you saw
a guy walk up because he didn't like
what somebody else said
or for whatever reason it's hard to
really know the reason that will smith
had in his head
people said all kind of stuff he was
gaying out or he was gayed out
people said his wife was
you know they have a
um
you know they do uh
foster cocking or whatever or when
people can make love to your wife you
know foster cox i don't know what it is
they do foster [ __ ]
uh
or [ __ ] fostering i don't know what it
is i don't i'm i'm not gonna look it up
either because i have a blocker on my
computer but
um yeah so they said uh so anyway but
there was a guy who said something and
then you saw somebody
a a rich guy on another rich guy
come and hit him
and then get an award for it
and it just kind of felt like this is
what it this was the this is where i
ended up really feeling the most anger
at the end of it all
was it was just really towards hollywood
towards the oscars towards the whole
[ __ ] machine of all that [ __ ]
it was like hey
we if somebody can hit somebody else
they can do whatever they want
they could say this man can speak or not
speed
so
and we'll we'll give that guy an award
and then
this is the craziest part
all of hollywood will stand there and
applaud the guy
as if the
the
the [ __ ] up thing he did didn't even
happen
and it was kind of like a microcosm i
think of everything that's been going on
you know
um
so many people feel like their reality
is neglected by hollywood
that uh
since hollywood owns a lot of the media
and and mainstream media that they just
uh
they just
that they're so powerful that if they
want to act like something didn't happen
they can just brush right over it
which they do all the time pick and
choose what they think
[Music]
or when they think something is
important or what they think is
important
so i think there was a lot of that in
there for me
and i hope chris rock sues the oscars i
would sue the oscars i would sue
everybody in that [ __ ]
you know
um
that's what i would do
because yeah they just that that's what
it was for me it was like
here's this powerful machine saying once
again
oh we determine how
if the way you see things is real or not
almost
or we think we determine it
because we all saw somebody hit somebody
and then
get an award then give an insane speech
and get a standing ovation it was like
they were trying to make us believe that
it didn't happen
in a way
which goes along with the whole pandemic
thing there's that all of that ties in
there
like oh you're gonna make me
you're really trying to bend me out of
the fact that reality is happening
so anyway that's kind of where some of
that landed for me
and maybe that's obtuse kind of and
but maybe it's not dude i'm just here
for limes
okay i'm just i walked in here for two
limes and now i'm an assistant manager
that's what's going on and it was wild
because spade took me to like a fancy
party you know he took me to a fancy
party dude everybody was in that [ __ ]
kardashians [ __ ] uh
um
kevin bacon's was in there everybody was
in that leonardo
uh
dicaprio and da vinci
both of them were i mean they had
seances in one room they had damn
spirits coming out of the back
christopher columbus was in that [ __ ]
everybody was in there
um kobe i think kobe showed up for a
half hour
it was uh
they were that's how fancy it was
they were recollecting people
and they were showing up
you know ed asner was in that [ __ ] who
else
um i don't even know anybody else family
i think i saw jesus over there by the uh
getting some watermelon punch i mean it
was they had everybody in there
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy
two
options watch one this one or this one
you